joining me now Chinese artist and
dissident I Weiwei in the studio thank
you very much for coming in AI weiwei
we just heard young Wang the punishment
will only be a matter of time
is this Beijing's way of telling
protesters that the Beijing government
can step in directly to stop them well
at least it tells the inner truth of
what's in their mind they have been
doing that since decades
you know they if happens in any place
within the land of China they would do
it they'll crash it this tanks or
military or whatever they have and
they're they can be very brutal and a
very bloody and but this is Hong Kong so
they are really bluffing you know they
are the the situation is much beyond
they can imagine and under those young
people are not scared they're not easily
you know to be forward or to you know
this is a life struggle so do you mean a
situation like the 1989 Tiananmen Square
protests would not happen in Hong Kong
IOC will not happen I I predict it can
happen but or be have a heavy cost on
China and that may become an opportunity
for China to change but do you think
China of what is about this cost are
China were is deeply and the the never
facing problem are such you know as it's
interesting a game you know it's not a
it's supposed to be one country to
system and that car they played very
well till today the one system and
demand its own more like in dependency
and and more clearly about their
identity so China is a really facing
problem but what is the next move of the
Hong Kong government for instance if the
Beijing government is facing a problem
what does the Hong Kong government do
next what are its options the problem is
in reality there's no such thing as a
Hong Kong government Hong Kong
government services of
you know puppy for central government
and whatever it does is really a
direction from the central government so
they're just trying to delay and they're
trying to to let the demonstration sees
itself but it doesn't it WA not happen
like that from everything that you're
saying it would appear that the young
protesters have the upper hand on the
government on the streets of Hong Kong
you yourself have been incarcerated by
the Chinese government in the past and
in a way understand how the Chinese
government thinks what are the debates
what are the discussions if at all
happening in Beijing or for that matter
in Hong Kong if I can put it that way
about how to end this so far as deadlock
now the Beijing would not lose its face
and they canal allow the Hong Kong
government to accept the Hong Kong young
people's very rational demanding you
know to not to call it as a right to
release all those peaceful demonstrators
under-22 to have some kind of election
and the same China never had as this
kind of tradition to listen to
demonstrators they have no no way even
to to to negotiate anything so it's very
very difficult
so we're unchartered waters but is that
what you're saying yeah it's um for both
sides is very difficult I just want to
go back to a term you used you call them
peaceful demonstrations you call them
peaceful demonstrators based on
everything that we've seen in the past
few weeks and particularly last night's
violence in which you had the protesters
surrounding police buildings would you
still call the protesters peaceful I
would call it a peaceful because on the
other side you consider you use violent
guns you know shooting people and I
write sultans protesters and
you know they are initiating some kind
of violence but for Hong Kong protesters
is through some umbrellas or water
bottles I think that's as peaceful you
can see when 1 million people
demonstrate I mean this is most rational
they even cleared clean up the street
after demonstration I just want to ask
you these protests have been carrying on
for about nine weeks now do you think in
your view they have done something to
the psyche of the people of Hong Kong
has this been a tipping point have
things changed in Hong Kong
I think Hong Kong cannot afford to have
demonstrations like that I have a most
important company stays in China which
have used with stays in Hong Kong Java
great deals working with China so it's
very crucial and enough for those young
people they have nothing to lose you
know they there as a generation realize
freedom our guarantee their life or
quality under this is what they want so
this in a way they can back off we leave
it there for the time being I weigh
weight thank you so much for coming into
the studio and speaking to us